volodymyr cnce qui en première ligne de
la plus grave crise que connaît l'europe
depuis la guerre froide mué en chef de
guerre d'une armée de près de deux cent
mille soldats alors qu'à son élection en
2019 il n'avait ni expérience politique
ni militaire face à lui la russie de
vladimir poutine et ses troupes
déterminé à démilitariser et des nazifié
l'ukraine selon les termes de moscou
objectif du président russe selon les
experts faire chuter le régime de kiev
il aura complètement annihilé toutes
capacités militaires du pays toute
volonté du peuple craignent à de
rejoindre des institutions européennes
et et de rejoindre a fortiori l'alliance
atlantique donc d'assumer sa pleine
liberté sa pleine autonomie pour le
ministre des affaires étrangères
français la sécurité du président
ukrainien est en jeu je pense que la
sécurité du président des aînés ce qui
est un élément central de ce qui se
passe maintenant et nous sommes en
situation de pouvoir l'aider si
nécessaire mais il apporte qu'il tienne
sa place mais pour volodymyr zelensky
hors de question de fuir son pays il ya
je reste dans la capitale ma famille est
aussi en ukraine les enfants sont en
ukraine
d'après les informations que nous avons
l'ennemi m'a désigné comme cible numéro
ma famille est la cible numéro deux
villes veulent détruire l'ukraine
politiquement en détruisant le chef de
l'état
les qui l'attend c'est un soutien
militaire de l'otan mais pour le moment
seul envoi de matériel et une aide
financière est prévue à l'ordre du jour